all right and we are love welcome to the
iron Lords podcast and the Lords of
gaming dotnet episode number 101 it's
another glorious Sunday we're back at
the roundtable and the Lord's Day I'm
very excited about our special guests
then we got borderland three rumors halo
infinite as a spiritual reboot pokemon
sword and shield reveal an apex legends
versus fortnight to discuss so we gonna
get right into it I want to introduce
the Lord actually some Lords of
podcasting who have the most respect for
these positive members in our gaming
community have been the pillar of
consistency intellectual debate and the
personification of what it means to be a
true gamer introducing the panel and
cofounders of the four guys with
quarters podcasts which includes one of
the most knowledgeable podcast host in
the game with the best Bostonian accent
you'll ever hear combined with
everyone's favorite wisecracking gaming
paisan and finished off with the
silenced trade partner at Cod newb
killer extraordinaire live from Beantown
Florida and West Canada first making
their debut into the realm of the Lord
together
mom made Lord Inferno two one seven
Italian clowns and z PCI assassin four
guys with quarters how are you lords
going doing well doing well doing well I
can't believe we're making this I can't
believe we are making this happen with
everybody on the panel this like cross
production going on we had you guys on
the past few months addict I know gave
me a little bit of flack from my mom
we'll have to get him on let's get him
on but I'm good glad to make this happen
man glad to make this happen on a
beautiful beautiful Sunday here and uh
in Boston so glad make it happen can't
wait to see you guys and what like three
weeks now it just looks absolutely van
know that absolutely pleasure Lord
clowns man how you doing good to have
you back in the round sir pretty good
pretty good no cows owns here so a
little bummed out I usually gets me
pumped up for the podcast and Lord
Assassin making his debut I'm very happy
lot of sense it's mating by the way how
are you doing sir I'm doing good all
cold thanks for having me here I had to
go to West Canada shout out I'm sorry I
had to it was like crown set it up last
hours to perfect it was too perfect I
had to it so glad your ticket is dry
that's cool so normally we have the Four
Horsemen of gaming but one of our lords
is down salute Lord Psalm he's got some
family things he's got to take care of
so we'll hold him down but you know we
still got the rest of the Lord's at the
round table my co-hosts were the Col
most my brother from another mother
the difficult game Conqueror and the
howl of the young wolf mommy
Lord addict I doing sir doing pretty
good sorry about my absence last week
the power in my area is pretty weird
don't know what's going on there but we
ain't gonna waste six of it in Virginia
I paid my power bill
[Laughter]
I didn't notice one thing I did miss my
presence last week because you because
you guys like King Cole a little too
much lastly know what it was
the represent for you at exciting give
up all it was two people worth it was
ever yeah that's everything is restored
in the channel it's a town good down
that's what I wanted
yeah now right now I'm playing kita more
concrete to the podcast and gamer at the
same time delvis and of course we had
the Incredible Hulk of this aka the
access game ooh the lord of combat
sports who was a man of his convictions
demands nothing less than that premium
experience and is the leader of the
fraud alert movement who beloved Lord
King how you doing sir yo this is
yesterday oh man it was so much stuff I
was a combat talk yesterday right now
and um I just didn't want to throw it
out because me and the UFC is just like
it's not me back in the days where I
used to know who was fighting for real
like I really don't know these dudes I
just have my favorite so I'm going in
with crazy bias so oh I watch the UFC
card
um kognito was really pissing me the
hell off yesterday because I was I was
taking I was working at the same time he
is tweeting out it's disgusting brother
it's disgusting so this is for you this
is for you right here at your ordinance
I almost crashed my car I'm like what is
he talking about
cousin lose oh no Ben Ben cuz I'm a
badass
that's for a fan right oh I know Dana
White said these two dudes up yesterday
right
so it was like here would Lisa with me
up and one of the Dean fell but asking
almost fell first some hands all the
time he got him with the pissed off oh
um big brothers to choke out late
beautiful hours all bunched up I was
like this I used to did too much
mixtapes problem he won't be the studio
like listen I gave I need a quick recap
when you seven a little bit just real
quick man
the thing with with the aspirin and the
law for that was the most explosive
explosive one round ever
tattooed up he looks sleep when he was
on the ground it stopped it on ask him
to get knocked out we did I think the
middle from this he like he was
responsive no he kept he kept he kept
scrambling he wasn't like completely
stationary then when he got up and he
got ahold of me yo right now his heart
his chin he showed me a lot as far as
it's hard once he got hold of all he put
that choke not a choke was controversial
cuz he did sink it in now for me as far
as Osama shot the Jay Fonzarelli we
talked last night and shot the meds we
did also when he put the choke on him
the big brother Joe yeah oh we live for
a second so we do did was out so I can't
blame the ref that once he stopped it
and the guy popped up like y'all I was
up I was still did you see his eyes
though like was it was one had a
whatchamacallit like a cut of it was
rolled in the back his head like he was
he was dead he was I mean the argument
could be made for a second he looked out
you know people people don't realize
that you know a couple seconds in it
show that you ain't supposed to be in
that show get hurt people dramatically
so they were talking about dad now the
Woodleigh thing man so disappointed man
I mean he came out sleep he had no
engagement like he look like he did not
want to mix it up and he was too
tentative and Nigeria was coming baby
not you know he didn't like the fact
that you just kept calling a Marty yeah
an old boy was on their head respect
because leading up to the whole the
press conference everything all the way
through the presentation everything he
kept the same energy from down again and
you know woodenly didn't keep that same
energy wittily just had you know one
line I think Willie just wants to go to
music no like she was worried about a
celebrity too
and to be honest the thing that won me
over when I was looking into our
Chamorro story is like he's a great
wrestler he's just like a d2 d3 wrestler
it is like the Division one dudes be
Lord no one was there and like he's like
yo I they know my name cuz I was the
best dude I used to rectum dues that's
honey that's why they calling me morning
from the class if I wasn't nobody they
wouldn't know me so there's what he did
and then he brought his kid out but then
we get to the arm to the main event for
me I watch the old court but we get to
the main event for me and um I really
thought um I called this card to set up
card because built for the setup and I
said Dana is just looking to cash in
these dudes like cashing the chips I
thought he was cashing in on Jones be
honest with you nine weeks out from a
fight then you're gonna get this fight
right here and then I was looking at old
boys on our pass face and I was like wow
but you know bones just showed me he is
top five greatest you know of the hands
he probably he's probably even even top
two mmm that ever did it and I'm putting
up there with hi Gracie type of top -
yeah he's a whole different animal to
stay off - whatever that is onon
picograms is what I think it is I think
the key to keep him going is to to not
allow him to get back into the whole
habits of the drug and and buggin right
so yeah he's something real quick he got
a scandal he was dominating I mean a
dude was just trying to hold on to do
really you know to win but the thing
that was scary was I think it was around
3:00 and Jones dropped him and he put
him up against the cage and the dude was
coming up normally you know when knees
down whatever they hang around you
cannot do the knee from that position
and he needed him it was clearly illegal
don't stop I'm like yo it could have got
the Roy Jones
it was always dqe gonna lose his title
so luckily when they told the car went
to go to the replay say yo was it
illegal they said yes so I'm like y'all
we definitely gonna lose it they go over
to homeboy what's his name Anthony and
they say can you continue Thank You Love
like you'll know no no I cannot continue
this scour your credit he's like nah man
I still want to fight and I was up
that's why I like you ever made news
because you can see in the boxing ring
do what it went to me okay so then you
know watch that and UFC caught a
beautiful card very fantastic card then
on a boxing note I watch our King Kong
on T's you know get one more step closer
to the heavyweight championship and I
watched my the Cuban sensation get up
and then win so it wasn't a great night
on boxing to be honest with you who's
just you know like caught you have a
great car coming up combat talk is gonna
be popping up soon you had statues
popping up over there you know you see
one on the table so soon as this is done
I'm by the Butte unboxing and get that
done but that's been that part um did we
go on to what we was playing for a week
oh yeah for you what she's playing what
you touch I played the mutant a zero
game that that uh had it put up right
cuz you know how do go support so I
watched this video ex-con to reverse
ex-con game bro he's talking about
mutiny zero yeah
game not that other X I'm gonna to talk
about that means zero game that game is
so fire it's like hard to put in words
if you into XCOM me and that it was in a
party chat talking while I'm playing the
game it is amazing what they did with
that game in his inside game passed for
free like I can't believe and I know
people are you corporate slave yeah yo
that game pass allows me to dig into
stuff normally I can't even afford the
purchases they I can't afford the
purchase of hunting games month but I
get the chance to touch stuff and I'm
looking at people reviews going back to
that whole fraud and stuff and look fine
a podcaster that you like fine a
streamer that you like and see they
recommend
test those games out and yeah
we walked away super impressed with
their game I'm still playing it now
absolutely it's funny because you said
that because uh me and Ferno we were
just talking about that on four guys
right we're just talking about in terms
of like exposure to get with games and
game paths that normally you know we may
not have given the light of day right
yeah yeah I mean a lot of people just
harping on that for having a lot of
filler they call it that's what they
called it the other day in the podcast a
lot of filler content I mean some of the
filler content is actually really good
the only reason you consider it filler
is because you're on the IGN's the game
spots of the world they give it at sixes
sevens you consider in that filler well
go try it out for yourself see if you
like it you know I mean like oh stop
following the recommendations of people
you trust actual gamers and not you're
not people like playing like a million
games a week you know pretty much -
stuff like Red Dead which is like a
snooze fest but now you turn no Kings
right news fast man if the horse is
literally riding a horse simulator just
put it on cinematic mode it looks way
better I'm like no I'm not put on a mode
just to look at the horse riding from
four differ and I'm not getting it I
said but then it gets cities posturing
you know open-world after you they
finish the mission a like oh you want to
go back with your team or do you want to
go you know go around where I'm like
okay I'm gonna go around the world oh
boy then I get caught up with some yes
kill somebody by mistake you know the
thing I hate the most because it's an
amazing game you just need to play for
like 20 hours 140 hour do you mean to
tell me I can watch the whole lord of
the rain saga four times before
I'd be I need the court is it here but I
need the Lord to go
Lotus ass let me guess assassin I says
what do you think you're man how did you
feel about red do you agree or were you
I would rend it oh the horse stuff
extremely slow like but when it ran out
of the horse stuff shooting people train
people with robes hunting animals like
that's fun but everything else I guess
you're a clown so it's in the budget for
you clowns like you are yeah I mean
there's a reason why Cowboys don't exist
anymore they're all dead boring
lifestyle riding the horses on out with
other men at campsite no clouds just
continuing his redneck slander from four
guys sounds yeah so is there an echo in
here [ __ ] I really continuing it's live
you should have heard of walk in here
any time and of course we have the Lord
of the cooperative gaming experience and
gaming in himself this should no be lord
kognito
spread never illness in the realm of IOP
now tell me what you want to hear what
you need to hear so for me tons of
division to open beta um touched a
little bit and I really want to touch
but then destiny dropped that season at
a drifter um that Vinick so I had to
start getting my character Randy and
there with my anthem talk so that was
that but uh are you only play for 5
minutes we was out there actually
sitting down trying to play for how you
spent most of the time using the card
that you neither a was on a loading
screen or be waiting for your step up
for your your engines to cool off I have
mastered the art of finding water
sources and swooping down low oh so now
we're looking for water sources ok I
guess my immense abilities out there we
get into freelancers it's still loading
I don't know
taking that money back like that they
still you at the cusp of the hours that
you can return the game and get your
money you'll check out the big cloud
gave it a bill to shout this stitch
shout to the freelancers in chat thank
you
[Music]
anyway but uh yo man I want to
definitely re-watch the episode 1 and I
definitely want to give the entire
gaming community a huge shout man it was
really cool to rewatch it and i want to
give some love back to you guys in the
room and especially actually lastly the
lord that i forgot to mention you know
with all the trunk and festivities king
you too except for mr. boomstick in that
you know this is the lord that kind of
remains behind the scene you don't guest
on podcast much these days but
definitely extremely integral to what we
do here at ILP and someone actually have
a ton of gaming discussions like daily
you know me so I lost a loop tip of the
glass to my brother Lord Chi Basu thank
you bro more things you doing respect to
the movement you are very much
appreciated and I want the world to know
that I'm getting my love on I can't not
on guys watch anthem Defense Force champ
you are not gonna slam to that it is a
great game maybe just don't know how to
play it I don't know how to play the
wetness so I definitely fall in that
category so the door you open the door
you gotta explain to me what it's like
to play the division I mean at the
division anthem what what what am i do
is so wrong that you know I couldn't
enjoy the game well how do I play anthem
yeah you gotta play as Colossus number
one all right I mean once you play as
Colossus you're gonna fall in love with
the game a lot more and I'm like Red
Deer Redemption so I got it I got a
limit the content got you sure yeah and
you don't have to play twenty hours just
two hours and then you'll start getting
into it
given two hours and then when they talk
their dialogue just keep hitting being
supinator that's the boring part you
know I can't listen to the story at all
god no no the story is let's go yeah
let's go it's all about you know getting
in those missions getting the contrast
the legendary stuff the strongholds
swells all they show on you to stuff
when you get it or you still got weight
to get to the house you guys real quick
man five Ilyich super chat for my lord
brap basement radio arcade by Comcast
thank you so much much appreciated in
the building like [ __ ] I'm gonna play
that game when they give you the
unsealed book back when they give you
the unsaleable back when that patch come
out there you can see what you got and
you can switch the stuff in the field
and you wanna be a real looter shooter
hey then I'm gonna be right in there
with my look at them is the worst bits
of destiny no it's the worst bits of
Destiny and it's the visual jetpacks and
all the you know for me the best thing
about anthem is I don't kind of wait for
like eight people to go noise stronghold
I just get like three people and I'm
rolling yeah there's some randoms they
know what they're doing and destiny I
suspend like the regret like three hours
trying to get people together that's why
you didn't like it see what see just for
you having no friends but you know what
that's why we was embracing people who
stuck our arms out there you know shout
out the of the cattiness image a ball
Chris you know we actually out there
playing every day so you will always
have somebody to play with on destiny
Wow disrespected division Hall it's
crazy I know you can't be fan of both
like yeah it's like very divisive thing
Inferno between these looter shooters
yeah red vs. blue yeah
dude anthem man and Infernus on the
anthem hate train don't listen to him
oh yeah not picking that thing up until
it's like 30 bucks so he's begging me
these guys are making me everyday anthem
I am yeah inferno you said 30 bucks
I say II access we got all mushy stuff
out the way and uh got into it the
Lord's own plan I want to start with the
Lords of quarters some of their video
game system history mind you Lord clowns
has already received the royal treatment
before please check out LP 55 for his
amazing gaming history iconic Toys R Us
stories and the best dad in the business
but also we would have discuss you know
the background formation of one of my
favorite podcasts out there those iconic
for guys so what let's start with you
Lord inferno
your video game system history kind of
what got you into gaming I think you
know what got me into gaming really was
I have an older brother who is 11 years
older than me so he was really the one
to bring the games in the house so when
that original Nintendo showed up when
like the game boys
you know the Ataris that I didn't even I
gotta be honest to you I didn't screw
around the Atari that much that didn't
really have my interest especially when
there's a Nintendo right there as well
for me but like also up here you know
just in New Hampshire there's the
biggest kid in the world Funspot I don't
know if you guys ever hit that spot up
but it is the biggest arcade in the
world and it has a ton of retro game so
I was totally into those the top of the
whole top floor is all retro games none
of that like you know time crisis or any
of that you know recent stuff all it's
all old stuff they all get all sectioned
off by by publisher and developer they
have like Namco section off Nintendo say
I like to have it all sectioned off like
that so you guys should well I mean you
guys probably I'm gonna be here long
enough but it's like a hunt it's so
exist yeah it still exists the biggest
arcade in the world it's like an hour
and 30 minutes north of Boston yeah it's
in New Hampshire
yeah the old-school style I think he's
in the wave she let him know well yeah I
mean that's kind of how I got in the
games because actually before I even
played games like in my home I was
playing in that arcade so I was already
like getting the bright lights you know
of the arcade setting and I was like
totally into video games cuz that and
you know when they finally got home and
I got those arcade ports like circus
Charlie like I remember distinctly
playing that on my NES you know like you
know the original Super Mario Brothers
and Donkey Kong like what hunt you know
that arcade still has like the combo
hunt and what's the other one clowns
it's with hunt they're like the cowboy
when I can't remember the game but it
has like all those old school ones that
made their ports to NES and that's when
I kind of like started gaming at home
and you know really enjoyed like some
retro gaming so so obviously after that
you know just bought everything I could
really you know what you transmitted
from the NES what did you transition to
you if you can remember did you like or
you skip no absolutely absolutely no I'm
you know I never had any SNES at launch
I was a Genesis guy so the same case
let's go and use some early what did 10
don't remember that oh my god how can
you not those are the good days of the
console wars no that's BS you see now
but yeah it so you know it transitioning
like with Sega staying with Sega like I
was one of the few people that had like
a 32x in my area so people were like
coming over checking that out 2x you
know get some flag and had some good
versions of some games like fantastic
anything to boost their Genesis up was
fantastic that CD
fantastic that their 32x on top did you
get the 32x combo or a CD yeah
absolutely dude
32x CD baby it was like the it's like
the Power Rangers like although it's
kind of gay
right baby yeah absolutely so yeah I had
that and you know it took a while for me
to go over to like you know like a
Playstation or something like that I
held onto the 32x CD for a while
actually
now PlayStation launch yeah 32 it yeah
yeah yeah the Sega CD I thought was
pretty cool like the you know maybe some
games like the real time video the real
time video stuff you know actually my
favorite I mean this may sound cliche
but I still even play it to this day is
Sonic CD I thought that was an amazing
Sonic game that's probably my favorite
Sega CD game and then you know the when
the Saturn came out like I really wanted
that thing and you know it took me a
while to finally get one traded in and
it was the worst decision ever I
recently read got it like got one again
maybe like a month or so ago two months
ago portal woods like before I got a bit
of a yeah it's with the two dollar super
jet can we all take a moment to pray for
ID Oh cuz they carry there's a lot of
Division versus Anthem slander going on
they're still continuing this in the
chat so that that's what that is they
what everyone to pray for dizzy for his
hate of MMO on consoles today's Jesus
Lord your they going in or dizzy right
now anyway Viper strikes viper strike
says snatcher he thought that the Sega
CD times continue I didn't yeah snatcher
was good I mean like night trap
obviously shining for CD I thought was
probably the best shining force game
today
which one was shark I never played I
don't think what that is the it that is
probably the most iconic Sega CD game is
about shooting rats in the sewer got the
attic can't wait to play that when we
were chasing [ __ ] you know a 16-bit you
know 32-bit when we chasing [ __ ] that's
what I thought it was really good with
consoles because we wanted
to be that next step 64-bit you really
wanted that bit to be at the end of your
joint but like so a sharp that you at
least like a video of it or when I fund
me for playing key Morrison you play no
that's other people to teach I don't
teach you funny thing that you play cut
it out
dude Sega CD had the best corny games of
all time
honestly like Willie Bemis you guys are
best game you know it had some good
fighting games too like Oh eternal
champions yeah exactly like other corny
games like wonder dog you remember that
clowns yeah I know you I know you
remember that clowns that came with the
Sega CD right yeah yeah that came with
it yeah came with it exactly yeah well I
think mine came with that that music CD
with INXS Funky Bunch one yeah yeah that
was that was like the full motion video
like very good quality music stage they
would really take an event any necessary
bump the graphics about people that they
had so much ambience around the game
with video and music real quick you
gotta pay the bill
shout out to Raymon morale final super
chair anthem is the load screen
simulator it to is somewhere in the
bushes awaiting a patch update you are
you missed went to neo meadow say can we
all take a moment to pray yeah unfocused
please not playing a game we at least
I'm open with my EP exactly what you're
up to
[Laughter]
got to hit that PayPal 32-bit era and
then on you say took you a while and
then you kind of transitioned over to
what was it that was it a place page
yeah actually actually funny story about
a funny story about the n64 I'll tell
you is that you know the n64 come out
it's like 96 or whatever
sixty-four comes out and I had no clue
that we were gonna get me a my my I have
a brother that's one year older than me
and her brothers 11 like I said and then
the brother that's one year older than
me was like oh if if we get the n64 for
Christmas it's mine and if we don't then
you can have the Sega 32x CD I was like
deal right because I never thought my
parents would get one cuz if you rode
back then the n64 I think was possible
to get man that thing was so hard to get
and of course my brother unwraps and I
64 and I was like no obviously I didn't
want to go with that bed like him having
the 64 right Lulu but like you know with
the drought of games at the 64 like I
played Super Mario 64 a little bit you
know we had pile of wings or whatever
you right yeah yeah I mean I think it
launched really like three titles or
something like it was it was
ridiculously low title count and then
you know the games were expensive so I
didn't want to use my Christmas money on
those games so it was like okay you know
I'll stick to I'll stick to my my Wonder
Boy and will he be much for and it was
about that life really good no no no
exactly I mean but you know 64 was hot I
didn't have a Playstation for a very
very long time
very long time maybe like four years
yeah yeah I took it took a long time for
me the PlayStation I was committed to
that 32x CD and yeah I was I mean
obviously the PlayStation stuff was
awesome but I just you know in terms of
just like buying games and I already had
that and you know I didn't want to like
start over with something new at that
age you know I mean and so obviously a
lot of the committee we know you as you
know an Xbox I would say the Xbox guy
you play everything but you you're a big
in the Xbox community so like how did
that love for minor sort of an Xbox
start like what was the kind of thing
that did it man you know honestly I
don't even know how I decided to get the
original Xbox I think it was just it was
coming out and if you guys remember back
in the day
EB Games was doing like three you had to
buy like a three game package mm-hmm
when you for when you pre-ordered it
when I was like 600 bucks it came with
like another controller and three games
something like that
and I I grab that and you know I thought
Maddon on that thing was just like too
legit after after after I played that
first Madden I was just like okay this
is this is real this is real and I don't
know I think my parents were just you
know not that I had to like necessarily
get their approval but like I always
kind of looked to my dad my older
brother for forgotten Suntech and stuff
like that when I was younger and and you
know Microsoft was obviously a name you
could trust then so I kind of just
grabbed an Xbox and then obviously the
360 kind of speaks for itself you know I
mean especially when you were kind of
like late on the PlayStation bandwagon I
didn't even have a PS like a ps2
probably get a ps2 it's like 2003 so I
was pretty late on the PlayStation
bandwagon so even this gen I don't think
I got a Playstation 4 until like 2000
what was it assassin like 2015 maybe
yeah yeah yeah interesting history now
that we got seed assassins type up try
billionaire so I want to get him to as
well like what about your gaming system
history uh assassin like the young kind
of like what got you into gaming so I
started with the n64 I was really young
when it when it came out mhm played a
lot of Super Mario Bros 6400 in Mario
Kart he's some Pokemon Stadium and then
he Pikachu which I still don't know how
that works with you to put that headset
on and talk to Pikachu and I'm like and
just it never seemed to work so I don't
think I got far um and then later on I
got I think the Game Boy Color okay
finally people talk about Dale's yes
continue I forget the games I played I
accept and watch Mars King somehow
switch is gonna get brought up and do
this now I used to play like a lot of
pokemon crystal and Zelda Link to the
Past and there were some other games but
I don't even remember them that I went
to the Gameboy Advance
nice unfortunately I sold the game style
for the PlayStation game make or
whatever ask was fraud it like I had
like a hundred players and yeah it was a
terrible yeah well you wait Wow
yeah I I was young don't like really
young those are the days we trade games
in those are the trade games and it was
like a quarter when Xbox right so you X
boxes coming out right so they said if
you bring in um DVDs that you get you
get for every DVD that you bring in you
get our 50% on the next DVD like for
store credit
I brought in two I had D football bags
right you put your football equipment
oh my I brought in two football bags
they could fit full-size bodies right I
brought two more bags in full of DVDs it
was like 2000 DVD yo the dude at the
counter was so pissed off because he buy
them they counted everything they
scanned everything through everything
went in it went from two shifts it was
from the morning shift at all right I
got I got um two Xbox 360s
with every game for like two years and
there's the reason they stopped that
promotion manager sent the email blog
look people are be using this stop we
take it to we have to take though the
mailman had to come in we got to get the
food dudes I have so much help to carry
these two
taking the DVDs I they not a worldwide
alert but anyway so your basic screening
you get mad and you gotta be frustrated
come back like years later I was I was
so upset because I had a Gamecube with
the the Game Boy Advance thing that you
plugged the games on played you know and
I didn't have any game so it's really
sad feel your pain bro how did you
bounce back what was the next big but
you get oh then I got the it was either
the Nintendo DS or is the Wii okay which
I had for the Wii for like forever
oh and then I finally got a ps2 for Star
Wars Battlefront 1 & 2 it's great games
mmm
then I went to the ps3 okay then there
were all right so I waited a few years I
got the when the slump came out I got
you despite of me logo on it
you got the other one I remember that
one mm-hm and then the Gloria are not
the glorious but the the knowing day of
no PSN for a month so pissed I traded
that thing and I got a 360 and of course
the day I traded and yes I went up Oh
[Laughter]
so I played I think I all I did was call
of duty but like the longest time not
knowing for sure the new killer and then
I finally went to some battlefield and
then though the one came out and I got a
ps4 instead okay so you're rocking it
you so you don't have the one yet the
ps4 just exclusively well I ran I think
a month or so they I got yeah thought
the wine and then I start with fair
enough young history when I like it man
so long clowns you know you all 55 and
you man mentioned that he had every
videogame system known to man so we
don't really need to recap too tough
because some of the public clouds
because we just need to confirm cuz
clowns you guys said something you know
I'll be 55 which was kind of cool and I
need to know is it true now that I got
all the Lords of quarters in the
building like I need to know is it true
that uh plants vs. zombies in party chat
is the reason for guys with quarters
exists yeah absolutely all of us
together
nah I become a Shinto says I become a
surfer - let me hear it
that's true it's true no that's true
that's true
I mean it's man that we used to play
with this guy that was an absolute it
turned out to be an absolute jerk on
Twitch like we all we all watch them and
then we ended up playing with them and
then you know this guy turned out to be
a jerk and we don't get in the whole
story but eventually we just like stop
we stopped chill with that guy instead
you know just playing pretty much
actually pretty much pretty much but yes
and then you know we're just playing
that game and you know we're talking
about like the kind of games we play and
you know kind of like getting to know
each other a little bit better and you
know we all had like some good opinions
on kind of differing stuff and we were
just like let's just start a podcast
like I obviously like knew how to do
some graphics work and in some
production work or whatever just through
PC and streaming or whatever so figured
why not you know
let's go modest you probably told them
yo you know I'm nice right everybody
gives nothing country with one cigarette
every time like people give me credit
like you're understanding for like
you're the standard that addict and king
always the open inferno did this yo he
can't have any I just told him last week
I just told him last week I said
get over there step it up you better
find out what he's using you are the
body keep comparing me to man I
appreciate that I appreciate it man I
appreciate it I mean we've been doing
this for a while and it's it's evolved a
little bit but I mean the core of what
we do is kind of the same and you know
I've changed programs a few times kind
of learned that stuff and actually you
know my background is no I'm really nice
and biology no I then we you know we
just got together we did a couple
episodes we had you know we kind of like
we're thinking about the name clowns
throughout some iterations of four guys
quarters like I don't know I can't
remember exactly how we zero down on
four guys of quarters but we're kind of
like okay well three out of the four of
us were kind of from the arcade era
obviously assassin I don't even know us
as have you ever even stepped into an
arcade row like honestly actually we had
one Kate even at Ferris wheel and
everything and then I got shut down
well the inferno is right what we did
was every the podcast idea was actually
a ferno's idea because he's like man I
listened a lot of podcast I love
podcasts so I want to get I want to do a
podcast all of us together talk about
what we like and then we set and I think
it was like Google Hangouts one day or
Skype or whatever and I drew out a bunch
of names like for guys recorders for
guys with blah blah and then the ferns
like yeah for guys with quarters sounds
good
and then I remember SATs are applied
with something like sounds like a bunch
of old guys
attic I can already see it was much
other than assassin it was a bunch of
old guys to start off and yeah three of
the original four I still around so I
mean majority rules it is stole God's
ass and so sorry so that's how it
started you just kind of took off from
there huh yeah I mean it's been like
five years now almost five years since
we started I think we started back in
like June or July 2014 and you know next
week will be 200 episodes I know you
guys you know celebrated 100 and that's
a that's a huge deal I remember 100
ourselves and I remember like couldn't
believe in getting a 100 let alone 200
and and you know it like it like you
guys kind of said last episode I watched
your episode last week and you know like
you kind of were just saying when you
recast here today it's like it's
extremely humbling to have these people
come and watch every week and you know
tell you they enjoy your stuff and you
know people that have given you like
recommendations and stuff and you take
those recommendations and roll with them
and it's it's rich it's really humbling
and an awesome that you know you can
build something out of that so
absolutely man 200 man you guys you guys
a double dose ready you guys are doing
it but that is really cool and
definitely you got to do something
special to two hundred do not let that
go verify that story ray I can't believe
it now or not assassin I got two
questions for you
so one what the hell is the PCI first
let's start with that what's that okay
so when I have my 360 I only have my one
friend so then I forget how I'm not
these guys but if
happened that I was in a party with
other people in Wisconsin
well why at least one person and I got
to know these guys they were cool clowns
no and infra knows him as Jaron and
they're their gamertag with Z PCIe
whatever I don't even remember they
change it so much okay so then you know
it's at the time still man
it stands for zombie pest control
incorporated which was it which is an
old game that they they enjoyed and so
one day I had a terrible gamertag I
don't even remember what it was and I
decided to pay the ten bucks and just a
CPC I said some and I never changed it
so now I don't like the stupid name are
you the old easy PC I run around him so
one of my friends who got a 360 later
Han has his name is Z PCI man man but
the other guys changed not law you know
like you'd only gotta got the tattoo
what's the zombies of the kizomba just
controller cooperate I got I got it that
a second what a little bit of more on a
serious tone I got a question for you
which was I wanted to highlight like the
awareness that you actually bring to the
color blind gaming community and I
really respect you for that because um
you know how especially how you make the
developers aware you know and um I guess
my question to you is like in your
opinion do you think that these options
are actually improving for gamers so
when they're actually good options which
99% of the games have terrible options
diced as excellent work with almost all
their titles at battlefield 4 and 5 I
don't know if hardline but they they do
beyond have you know anyone else they so
I don't feel when you say dices like one
of the top farmers but they set the
standard and ever
just here on the floor playing better
for instance apex legends right they
have this ping system and this whole
like colored loot you turn the pick that
you turn the color by an options on cuz
I'm red green colorblind so when someone
pings and I'm me it turns red well when
you turn those colored options on the
red goes to red oh so it doesn't do
anything anything here I think it's Tier
three loop which is supposed to be
purple trim sea of blue tier two loot
which is blue stays to blue so it's
really kind of annoying I'm different
you know what Lulu Oh Call of Duty for
instance when you turn it on the enemies
turn yellow but let me play in a desert
map which is yellow you can't see me see
ya
or anthem heroines favorite game you
turn it on it makes the white people
extremely white like albino white
doesn't change anything else it just
makes them albino I'm like that's I mean
reading green to begin with
Wow Wow hold on one quick sighs gotta
pay the bill
shoutout to Fastback OG n LG podcast
with the $25 super chat with mine was
the last you missed episode 100 hit that
like and subscribe these great
entertainment positive gamers and throw
these anthem hater opinions in the
bushes Lord kick so good girl yo thank
you brother fastback man that's our
energy fam I see a lot of you guys at
the chat thank you so much bro but not
continue on mortis asset because um it's
important and I'm glad you highlighted
it that as far as
dicing them being like one of the top
guys as far as the color balcony now I
just wanted to mention um I know you're
not probably a destiny fan but I did
recently see you and then next season of
The Drifter content we have like these
armor sets that Alexa Pacific colors
that's going to kind of correspond to
specific roles they're going to
introduce and I was shocked that they
mentioned all these color brown options
I think for the first time I've ever
seen
do it now did the base game I know
you're not a destiny I did the base game
did you play it was anything in place
for it so there was there's colorblind
options and the game when it first
launched never might it kind of ruined
the Green was brown and I'm like like
and then the Greens want to change so
like on Titan or whatever the water
planet thing and that's gay too like
there was some green lights like none of
that would change it just drops so it's
like thanks for half asking every time
guys so salut right now it's diced in
its battlefield that's the the gold
standard yes they let you change
everything if you don't like the blue
enemy or a teammate color you can change
that goal you know change act like
everything anything I has a color you
can go right and change it because I'm
ignorant when it comes to the colorblind
issue so when I thought it was
colorblind I thought it was like devoid
of color wait no actually you see like
colors like daringly so like a lion for
instance you take that thing off it like
it might look one shade of green to you
right look different shade or red like
for me sometimes it looks more pink or
sometimes the orange the pain okay and
everything just it can like for a text
like you won't be able to see it it
looks like a blur to me for like Metro
Exodus the when you look at the map the
player icons like a weird red I don't
see that so it's like even a friend can
say like you
if I was lost and surely am because all
I see is this giant circle on the map
[Music]
I'm glad you spoke up on it and like I
said um
just bring awareness to it a lot of
people don't realize that and it's
definitely something in our community so
so look to you for like I said I noticed
your Twitter account you're always kind
of like pioneering now you're always
speaking to the developers in reference
to that so definitely want to give you a
shout out that's real positive but um
yeah man actually we're gonna wrap this
up as far as the gaming history but um
so actually Inferno and assassin I gotta
start with you two first
um infernal the question that we ask all
the guests it is your time top five
video game franchises of all time your
mouth well honestly man different we
single you know I mean I don't know if I
can order them top five like that I mean
for me honestly is NBA 2k recently
recently it's been a little rocky but
like man those games for Dreamcast were
iconic even like leading into the early
days of 360 like those graphics were
insane the gameplay was so good and I am
a big NBA fan like I make sure I go to
like probably five or six games a year
at least so I was there last year when
they lost the game seven to the Cavs
unfortunately but but it was a good time
nonetheless whatever but yeah NBA 2k is
definitely definitely up there Mortal
Kombat for me iconic iconic game
franchise what what can you say really I
mean the new one coming out it looks so
hot can't wait until next month for that
what else we got battlefields honestly
like in terms of shooters like
battlefields my jam and like I've played
pretty much every battlefield and when
they when they come out even best
battlefield 5 everyone not to knock it
even hardline when everyone was knocking
that it was still on there playing that
destruction oh yeah yeah was there well
before I like no I did no it was good it
was good I mean
people will like come to me and asked me
you know my top outfield games of all
time or whatever and we'll disagree or
whatever but you know some of them were
really iconic like Bad Company 2 like
that was a really good one can't wait
for that
hopefully they bring that franchise back
it's been taking too long but whatever
speaking of something we're gonna talk
about today Borderlands
I mean Borderlands 2 one of my favorite
like shooter RPGs of all time it's
probably the best of all time my opinion
you know pre sequel was a little bit of
a letdown but still like took on some of
the gameplay aspects in four lands too
so I was still into it well and then you
know man what else really what else I
mean I really love Sonic dude like Sonic
like I said with the Sega games like I
had pretty much every Sonic game even
through through the bad times you know
like some of the 360 games i mean yok
dude Sonic Adventure though sonic
adventure 1 & 2 those are my jam you
know Sonic 3 obviously excellent Sonic 2
excellent
I had a game gear for a very little
amount of time a Dreamcast I had a
Dreamcast yeah I forgot to say that
during my history ad not definitely a
Dreamcast oh and yeah I mean Sonic
Adventure wanted to had those on there
those games were like lit I mean though
sonic adventure games I really wish they
could just bring those back in some
capacity to that level I mean I know
they've tried but maybe the landscape
has changed and there's no market for it
anymore now this regular market but I
really wish they would because those
games was so great and man one more one
more that I just truly love haha man he
said man you have to come back to me on
that I can't think of one off the top of
my head I probably felt written analyst
good we go we go hold on you're full and
did we go later assess I need some
privacy so let's go Oh see the Uncharted
series absolutely
uncharged for is they did Drake but uh
definitely the plants vs. zombies garden
warfare Mike we're doing like I've been
giving that game a lot of crap read
so money but I mean I love memories of
that game and some really annoying ones
like you're not the world record for
coins Call of Duty I know I runs like
all Call of Duty I play that game so
much if you match me my young gunner mjd
boss reverses you but inferno city girl
gets killed by you yeah I should do it
if I need to protect my young got his
life to putting Kings turns I'll be a
round one knockout a train Babel Train
MJ - boy I heard about you - assassin
argue he's legendary what you do what
else the the star wars battlefront games
the old ones are the new ones they
always have a place in my heart for the
old ones and then probably the rock band
slash Guitar Hero games I can't I can't
play those games anymore there due to
some nerve issues but I used to get used
to be jamming you know that's what's up
inferno I let you have to hook come on
man one more let's go ahead and do die
just trying to think of something they
have a good story that I do rock it was
actually a great one dude I used to host
rock band parties all the time hosting
party baby had a smash bros just say the
anomaly dawg what do you think is one of
his favorite games of all time and
clowns what do you think was one of his
one of his top Bobby
what are you okay I'm gonna announce
three that I think might be in there
okay Mario Kart series smash bros
or Mario all-stars my cats probably the
closest in terms of game played but you
know dude you guys are there weren't you
[Applause]
a good memory until I had to pay like
the extra $50 for the carrier for the
check bag this man is heavy but nah dude
that wasn't good that was a good moment
that was a good moment no no no yeah I
just said III 2016 champion it's
probably not gonna come through very
well in the video but anyway good clouds
we gonna let you end this segment off
bad that last of IOP like I said you
were on your top five was specific I'm
gonna throw it back at you I just want
to know if anything has change your top
5 at the time of Io p55 was Super Mario
Kart
I mean Super Mario Mario Kart donkey
kong country Battletoads and Double
Dragon has anything changed or shall
that remain the same
well you know now that I got you know
many weeks to think between and I should
have put Megaman in there so let's knock
Donkey Kong out from Megaman well aren't
we updated right now I'm updated on the
fly all right Megaman building and
everything else routines it's by Super
Mario Brothers Mario Kart Battletoads
Double Dragon
and now Megaman yep all right mom man
all right great video system history by
the Lords of quarters
we will get into the show we got a show
to go so last week's poll results are in
and the people have spoken to the
question with the latest rumors
regarding game paths coming to switch
and xbox scarlet devices being revealed
at e3 2019 if proven true do you think
it will be a tactical mistake for Sony
not to be present in any capacity during
e3 the winner of the ILP 3 well poll at
69% is the yes
scarlet head start and switch
partnership will provide huge momentum
group coming in at second place at 27%
was that no Sony is still the dominant
force of this generation their games
will dictate the gen group and coming in
at last and only 4% was I don't care
next gen doesn't really start until
Google says so the Lord clowns what do
you think about this you know I as far
as e3 is concerned I'm more excited
about PAX nowadays so I'd really don't
think it's gonna hurt Sony in any of the
least by withdrawing from e3 as long as
I still got stuff to show at other
conventions okay okay could survive be
any type of onslaught that comes their
way right as far as he's concerned yeah
I mean there's no sound system so Lord
addict what do you feel about this poll
do you think they can survive but not
being there with the whole news these
rumors coming out when Xbox Nintendo
game past yeah you gotta want me I don't
think
it's going to like destroy their
momentum or anything like that but I do
think that it just depends on what
Microsoft and Nintendo dude like if the
thing is is what around III one of the
biggest advantages that Micra that Sony
had is they were the next day so pretty
much they would stop the momentum with
whatever Microsoft did it in a day now
you're gonna have two whole days that
people were just talking about Microsoft
from Sunday to Tuesday mm-hmm
you know I don't if they go to other
events like I get it you know that you
you want a presence in every every
corner of the world but everyone around
the world looks at e3 gotcha
so I just don't understand how you if
you have any kind of it's like supposing
right now the Last of Us is coming out
in October some kind of leak I don't
know out it but let's say that does come
out in October like that game don't
necessarily need to be you know shown at
an event like that but they could
literally go out there for 30 minutes
show a giant game play of Last of Us and
show an October release day and that
would satisfy be a good point strainings
coming out like if people's like oh they
have nothing to show no release dates
they've been doing the same thing for
years they show the same game for two
years in the third year they show all
the release dates mmm so you think they
could literally just stick to that
formula sure release date have a new
trailer last of us boom nothing about
the multiplayer of last of us mmm yeah
and we've seen one good trailer of Go
sakushima like there's stuff they could
show but I want to sleep and truly think
that you know they got butcher for last
year I think last year's e3 conference
might have haven't been pulling out
weight because last year's e3 conference
I never seen someone go at Sony like I
did last year yeah it was it was rough I
mean again Phil Hannibal if they Dean oh
here we go I don't necessarily think
they're gonna be hurting but if
Microsoft comes out for really
good show it's coming in it was a really
great show last year if they show off a
really good show
and there's nothing to combat that like
nothing at all not first let's say that
Nintendo shows Pokemon direct and that
you know they show some Pokemon they
show Pokemon they show you know animal
Crossing's you know that might that
that's gonna be big for people this show
Reggie walking out the door that's gonna
be big for people with people really you
know not the third parties you know and
I do think that to a point people are
gonna stone Microsoft's cuz a lot of
things that these platform holders are
used is okay you know one of the state
the incentives they use to do marketing
does is like will give you time on our
stage at e3 and like you're not giving
your third parties that advantage that
you're doing the marketing with yeah
like I don't understand they didn't even
do a conference but they're not even on
the floor for the fans that go to e3 and
I feel like you know the people that say
oh they don't need to go III like it's
like what world do you live in what
grapes is what they got to do with it
you know they don't they don't have to
be there in terms of press conference
but I feel like it's an insult to not go
there for your fans to let them play
your game we got that out the way let's
get you the news every alive down no
weapon I start off with something that
kind of broke late in the weekend
Inferno and I would kind of loot it to
it at the start of the podcast so um it
seems
gearbox may have some major reveals for
us so um yeah it's going to attention
that on you know gearbox obviously you
know the studio behind Portland's
brothers an arm stuff PAX East man it's
coming and um there's announcement right
now I actually want a Thursday or pax
that all yeah it's gonna have a show
that's gonna take place between 2:00 and
3:00 p.m. and pretty much what they
state it is pretty much this is your
opportunity to kind of
see or statements you kind of
opportunity to see a lot of the stuff
behind the scenes and updates and then
it says the keywords never-before-seen
reveals exclusives and surprises also
misshapen frontal someone told her
suppose me that was uh those attic okay
attics I guess I was like saying you
know ones that they announced and it
comes out the same year like this year
it could be interests man so everyone
yeah everyone is betting that this thing
could be born and lands three and this
is most likely because I get Idol born -
oh my god this guy's a hater but um yeah
mostly because like I said take two they
promised a major franchise in fiscal
year and stuff like that and obviously
we know it was kind of like a no-show
last year so wanna bring this to the
table I wonder arm actually start off
with Laura inferno um our fellow
Bostonian here you know there's so long
yeah man what do you think about this
news like about a possibility of
Borland's three with man man let's just
say that I'm glad I only lived ten
minutes away from the Convention Center
because if they announced this thing and
it's playable I'm gonna have to run home
for a change of pants but for real
though I think it is it I mean listen
they say they were working on it back in
2016 it's been three years now nothing
to show like you said big franchise come
in this year you know they gotta make a
they gotta make a splash it makes sense
that they're doing it on the Thursday
you know pretty early on you know they
just added the fourth day last year this
thing and right in that first day you
know it doesn't make sense in terms of
attendance because you know Thursday's
usually I kind of light there at the
show but in terms of making a splash and
getting the name out there right away
getting that news out there for I'm
gonna talk about all the press it makes
a it makes it makes sense and I don't
know if it's gonna be playable I mean
that'd be awesome if it were playable
but you know I think that they they've
obviously been working on it it's about
time you know addicts joked around
saying battle one two if now born
obviously underperform significantly I
think they expected that to do a lot
better and I think maybe I think maybe
they were actually prepared to release
us you know
a little earlier but they probably
couldn't because of like the destinies
and the anthems and the divisions coming
out kind of changing the landscape but
what that kind of game could be you know
not necessarily thinking that
Borderlands is gonna take some notes
from not destiny and and become like a
true looter shooter but I mean like it
was kind of the the grandfather of those
games right in a way so maybe you know
maybe they were maybe they were ready to
kind of come out in one form but then
they saw what was going on with those
other games and said okay you know let's
go back to the drawing board a little
bit let's not release our trailers or
anything and let's you know maybe add
some new elements to it they kind of fit
in with what today's landscape is for
looter shooter so who knows a so almost
like a almost coming with like aw they
may reinvent themselves to an extent
it's kind of witty going just exactly
exactly show a little bit of evolution
cuz I think they come out the gate you
know with Borderlands 2.5 essentially
you know it's uh you know people will
like it but it won't be people will be
asking you know what's new you know I
mean we don't want just new for new
vault hunters you know they want they
want something new you know and
something worth it so I think they've
got it got a call somewhat out to check
I call this the kiss of death y'all
remember this y'all watch this podcast
it's botched her episode 101 101
anchorman VIII has given boy last three
the kiss of death he said it is the
Destiny killer every game he says is the
Destiny killer has failed so here we go
do we through division what all these
were his SP killers and now added to the
unfortunate list is more lines through
the bushes calls d76 is a killer but
it's the Bethesda destiny killer
anyway take your fertile I wouldn't get
up let me get us asses in class um let's
get assassins what do you feel now you
if it's Bordelaise through well watch it
nappy boy lands three hits like four of
lambs battle royale or
[Applause]
you would destroy me with that assassin
you know that Battle Royale baby come on
oh yeah Mariella claptraps in psycho
[ __ ]
yes son that sounds awesome let's get it
you know even more awesome portal in
three plus better oh yeah okay oh no
with you I'm with you on it if it's an
additional mode I'm which III I want it
to be the only mode because I want to
see the world burn oh my god I can
imagine Lord kognito on Twitter after
that's announced yeah I'd be destroyed
shout out the slobo he said I feel boy
lands 3 is in development hell it's been
supposed to be reveal so many times it
ends up not showing so assassins you
really don't think it's a you think this
could be a battle royale game no I I
don't think it's gonna be a battery I
was really almost like some handsome
Jack like didn't like when the Masters
come on like if there was enough
interest they would they would throw
that out and I think if a few months ago
or whatever it came up again or
something I don't yeah I don't know
you're right you're right if that happen
I think people would be upset if it's
just a remaster I I think have they
given the law of like maybe Resident
Evil 2 you got nice to choose that
extent but you know gave it more love
than here it's 1080p or 4k and go play
with that you know giving will give my
lovin many people would be alright and
happy but not like as happy as like you
know half-life 3 came though yeah gotcha
gotcha clowns how excited are you about
this potential possibility oh man if it
came out I'd be ecstatic like I just sit
on that game forever trying to create my
own new guns constantly you know through
the PC somehow but yeah I mean I would
just
I love that game I still go back to
Borderlands 2 I think it's one of the
best games that has ever been created
agreed my girl all right Kay I need to
hear something because I don't know
where you stand
going up to space and into that jet
packs to try to make it like it's a
little crazy thing my son plays
Borderlands right now so I mean he finds
it to be amazing um and with the million
done thing I thought it was really nice
so I like the game I like the storyline
and yeah I would love some battle royale
and it makes it look bad boys sprinkle
it on kick you kind of in that bold way
like sometimes if a game doesn't have
PvP and it's PvE only you tend to throw
it in the bushes so good up the only bat
Borderlands satisfied no no sure watch
only just for me because really all
right see this is where my fraud meter
comes in exactly I don't really pay PvP
but everybody on my gamers list does so
if Chris is playing he's playing trials
or whether he's really pissed off with
destiny right now their trials doing it
well yo he is he is so pissed off and
I'm like why because I don't get that
part right in the heart of nothing the
equivalent of a knife oh no equivalent
of a ray for the peeking for the PvP
community and it sucks so that's what
that's that's what he wants right so but
usually when they're playing and they're
pull me and I'll play with them and so
but when mayhem comes up oh man monkey
in LA we can average right now like we
can average okay so we're jumping you
know if you don't have that aspect of
camaraderie community friend
shipside but then you get like 80 your
friends or 60 your friends and you're
going and just wreck shop or have fun
like running tears you know we're on a
six-game winning streak if you don't
have that other aspect to your game and
you just limit it to a horde mode um I'm
sorry like the competitive nature of
some people are so great that they need
to dominate another person in order to
achieve that that that level that
they're looking for in a video game so
if it's not it's worthless now Lord Lord
addict Oh what's your history with the
model in series and how excited are you
if this is true uh what I like the
sirens that's about all thank you for
your lack of contribution I answer the
damn question like that's literally all
like I like the sirens and that's pretty
much like the only people are playing
the games I never beat the second one I
don't think I've played much of the
precinct when I beat the first one
that's literally my entire history
report oh really so alright let me ask
you the question I asked King though
what if there is it what if it
Borderlands right but um there's no PvP
no additional mode let's battle royal
stuff you talking about like is that
enough for you do you think like if they
can yell enough oh cool so you think as
long as they show me good unique
characters it's enough hold on they go
now I got a call for you because I just
Lobos go ahead now you have said in the
past without any game and without raids
your enjoyment of said looter shooters
is in the bush this is different than
that no this is an online community
thing like this is just something you I
don't consider them to the same looter
shooter if anything I would consider the
division and destiny and stuff like the
you know the more centric MMO loot
shooter then then you know your standard
just go and kill the people grinding for
guns like that's completely I don't even
consider than the same game at all like
it's almost like a first present dungeon
crawler almost a Bluto shooter yeah like
you know that that's I feel like the the
the atmosphere of Borderlands has sold
the game probably just as much as the
looter shooter aspect
figuring that the humor the document we
used to like tales from the border and
the tell-tale game it kind of introduced
us to that whole you know narrative for
people could never play at least for me
and I just I honestly don't understand
you could even compare destiny or the
division or anthem to borderlands like
just because just because like you know
you have that aspect of getting Luke
does not mean that they're the same gang
yeah a little bit I guess why I get
people make that Association because
they kind of originated that whole thing
right in front of ya loot and having the
same Gumbo's different roles and just
behave so fundamentally different and
it's unique with the properties and
stuff but I see what you're saying egg I
mean I see what you're saying like in a
sense that yo like it's it's different
and still in even though it's in the
lunar shooter genre it's its own kind of
space yeah I jump in real quick man yeah
huge surprise when I heard the news I
mean definitely long overdue the
Borland's community been waiting for a
long long time i'm dinah see like if
they take what they do i can put a new
take on it you know we all consider it
kind of like the OG the granddaddy of
the lunar shooters um I miss I remember
like missing out on launch a head like
that cel-shaded look you know Sam but I
did like the humor yes a unique Lou
co-op was lit I want to see if they
evolve on that you know I'm saying I
think the game gonna do really really
well and you know inferno or the Lord's
gonna be in a building that packs for
this one K gonna be right we gonna do
this thing man we gonna see in our last
question do you guys take this year
release anybody Pro ya know probably I
think I think that they kind of have to
write if they want to get it out on on
these consoles right I mean I think
there's there's two possibilities one
they announced a borderland one remake
and then they announced at e3 of
Borderlands 3 mmm
nothing because I feel like a
Borderlands 3 is III worthy and it's
weird
yes it is it is now here's the dig if
that's the case good you would think the
platform holders would kill to try to
promote that game do you think they're
gay
obviously it would have to be almighty
if it's gonna be 83 Microsoft stays the
marketing rights might go to Microsoft
you know if it does come out yeah that's
a tough question it's hard to say
because I think Borderlands can stand on
its own without anyone needing marketing
rights always gonna get the marketing
rights regardless if you could sound in
your own someone's getting the marketing
but Institute gave the playstation
marketing rights every game you get
marketing rights that's in a year where
they were going to e3
now what is your bargaining chip like
we're gonna promote you where you go
promoters we're cuz you're not gonna
beat here so we are you gonna promote a
set default by default that's what it is
by default Microsoft will get scooped up
a lot of stuff by default that stage is
gonna be he says Microsoft has them
though you think he thinks I'm not sure
if anyone has confirmation that
Microsoft has the rights I'm not sure
anyone nothing I know of not that I know
of
yeah going to next-gen it wouldn't
surprise me if Microsoft did do that for
a next-gen you know if they're gonna
start promoting next-gen I think if you
want my opinion you know I think they're
gonna start laying off of those kinds of
deals I don't think they're gonna do a
whole lot of third-party those much
going in the next-gen I think that was
their mistake this generation losing
those third-party deals
I listen I agree with you too but I like
the direction they're going doesn't make
me think they're gonna like double down
on third parties like it seems like you
know they've invested so much in the
first parties that you know they're
they're kind of like they're not going
away from the console market but you
know they're not highlighting it either
so hmm fair enough fair no see what
happens but uh that's all I got a bonus
extremely excited you know what's the
news broke we'll see what happens Lord
addict what is going on with Nintendo
man's Pokemon doing something did they
announce something
yeah so uh first off I want to point out
that uh you know it's a shame I think I
think Lord sovereigns frauding up here
needed nobody beat you up you know he
didn't want to be on trial and have me
throw the throw on but it's okay you
know I would like it's not your Pokemon
it's our contributor I got the old shelf
King against the wall he's a holdup kid
and let me get him the me bow
me rare items to bust the boss upside
the way that lord king seek Oh Lord
alpha-1 Chico
there's been a new Pokemon game
announced weird it's called a sword
shield that's about apparently there's
some rumor that there's gonna be like
instead of mega evolutions it's gonna be
like like armored evolutions which I
have no clue what that means but you
know this game looks like it's one away
from the let's go trash this is what I'm
saying like do I get a chance to use
them is it Pokemon really let's go
Pokemon oh the evolved form of that
amiibo okay listen
like evils in it you got a head start on
you right no functionality just quick
shout out so King if you need to add to
your collection
Ivan below now sells amiibos to now it's
a new pokemon game it's a sorted shield
it's probably going to come out this
year I would be very surprised if it
didn't new region new pokemon they
announced the three starters I the
Powerpuff Girls
like what they I wanted a point about
these new Pokemon because it's been like
you know leaks and evolution trees of
all of a bunch of them like they look
weird like it is very apparent that they
ran out of ideas
oh yeah looks like one is just a ninja
when he's younger he gets older he gets
a little bit bigger and he gets a sword
in his third evolution like I kid you
not
you know shout out their photo you
showed
be the likeness of what it looked like
they were taking they take inspiration
from it
oh yeah yeah a little bit of inspiration
I mean when we were talking about this
on the quarters on Thursday I I
suggested that they may have a little
bit like it's so similar man it's way
too close wait house and he's got it I
gotta put it I gotta find it it was
amazing how crazy let me get
assassinated kick um assess like what do
you feel man where you at without poking
my sword and shield yeah I mean it just
looks like another Pokemon you mean like
the last Pokemon game I played was
probably Pokemon Stadium 64 so I meant
oh you can tell you Ross the gods you
could make a Pokemon state even for the
switch I was definitely so what does a
traditional RPG Pokemon excite you to
assassin like well you get with that
well I'm dying to play like a Pokemon
game right good Samford switch and I
heard the potent argument whatever it's
called is okay it's not great
so having like a traditional game it
didn't raise the bar didn't lower it
what kind of lower did a little bit but
like not dramatically no doubt and Lord
King are we going all the way through
lose their guess so showing up this guy
is this right and I'm going to find them
below the day you bet I don't have a
will has if you got it I'm gonna get it
best believe that part and I'm gonna get
in there with the fraud or II I'm gonna
jump levels ahead of you I'm gonna come
out there with the strongest buff no man
I will let you use anything you want
shut up lame you already lost your knees
just because really gonna tell me if you
wanted it that's fine listen Maddie
wisdom this
I'm saving you from save from yourself
right because i'ma save you from
yourself if they said that I can use
amiibos so you best believe I'm gonna
use them I'm gonna get me game we're a
buff character you don't come in with
your little level one character my
character gonna have some type of
magical extra and I'm going to use it on
you and you will yell out what are we
doing this because you've been trying to
get your knees back forever
look you listen if we got amiibo
functionality imma get it okay and I'll
play you with that buffed up amiibo
parent and I'm gonna beat the breaks off
for you and I don't want to hear help me
I can't feel my legs
because I'm taking your kneecaps again
breathe I never get you because it's
gonna be like 20-25 you gonna still be
out here on rollerskates
I really think you should I'm telling
you he can use all the me both scream
i'ma have you screaming all laughing you
gonna cut your camera you gonna rage
quit you go Buster control let me
explain to you how this is gonna go
alright so you know right now Kings
being extra because you know Kings extra
but what happened is the the podcast
after this showdown happens the first
thing coming out of this man's mouth is
gonna be this is Gary's employee whose
whole wife don't really expect me y'all
see this right y'all see him right all
right
I want y'all to see him you know all
right listen listen when they say put
your eyeball on the screen that's going
to be read right I'm gonna faze him in
he's not power up and he number like new
amiibo just launched in the match at
swing your behind is done you ain't go
have nothing to do with it you out here
actively seeking ELLs never see my body
after they'll also be kiss of death or
IOP whoever sides with addict takes on a
bet is do you are gonna get
flame-broiled I'm gonna make you hate
your game like that is stupid like your
purchase you're not gonna like you're
gonna take this if this game gives him
that marketing you're good at placing on
steroids give him at the end of the day
it's gonna be coming on with you I'm not
gonna front
this guy's suffering with Alzheimer's
and I'm telling you right now I got
perfect memory bro you ain't that nice
and I'm gonna clean it with an advantage
I don't care you know I'm trying to save
you from yourself I was trying to be
nice King miss 2019 I'm trying to you
know nice guy I'm gonna swallow you
whole Pole
what do Benson say you better hope they
don't have pokeball go support it is
what it is he don't even have Pokemon
baby
the rest of the forecourt is it love if
they look close me I need your feedback
pokemon sword shield jumping you know
it's just another Pokemon game so I'm
not that excited for it next set up baby
wait for that price to go down - yeah
yeah bargain then give me that liquid I
wish you had a you ready for this one
I am ready for this I am ready for this
I didn't get the let's go cuz you know I
do when they were advertising that and
they were showing off like that little
pokeball thing that you like throw your
switch but not really and I was like
okay this isn't a real Pokemon game this
is just some some some kid stuff but as
I'm talking about Pokemon right but
anyway what are you saying that a good I
said that's all Pokemon let's go was was
fluff right there you go that's perfect
fluff fluff but this is the real thing
I'm excited for it I really wish it were
like you know throwback to the old
school kind of stuff I know they're
gonna introduce some like new school you
know like this armored evolution thing
that he was talking about just keep it
simple keep it like the tried-and-true
formula like but I know I know they're
gonna go off the deep end a little bit
which is gonna hamper my enjoyment a
little bit but I'm hype jae-won on it
pretty much the rest of Louis the other
panel I mean I'm just happy for addict
to you in the sense that um this is kind
of a honker cargo game that you guys
want you don't mean so you got your
random Pokemon encounters Wow Pokemon
and the gems are back to right yep yeah
back turn the other one now I got one
question for you hard core Pokemon dudes
um how come like they got two outfits
this year right but how come they don't
got the character created let you
customize your face and everything so
you could be in the game I never
understood that always go like that's a
missed opportunity that I can't myself
and uh yeah like oh no oh wow yo $10
super Chad Jonathan B King a statue
is fire but now we need king of amoeba
sorry to interrupt you were cooking I
was some some hashtag anthem in the
bushes in the UK you gotta help me man
we gotta get these people put some hash
tag in that Jonathan that right there is
a premium format Batman figure exclusive
that that's gonna be unboxing so you're
gonna get a chance to see that and I'm
gonna do a whole amiibos and
whatchamacallit Disney infinity launch
through I'm gonna sit there and do that
but it's gonna be like a slideshow so
you can see every last one of them you
know there's so many range but yeah man
I just always felt that like a missed
opportunity with the character created
thing regardless man my feelings and
whatever this thing is gonna sell like
hotcakes like no you know once they put
I mean I'm never gonna put this on sale
oh I don't know feelings about that but
um nah man listen at the end of the day
this is gonna win you know you're
looking for that q4 released a kind of
similar what they did was smash kind of
kill a retail killer MPD and what's
crazy is them announcing it so early
because I thought they were going to eat
in the hole for III kind of what they
did with a smash as a whole smash direct
so that gets me excited that III might
be something else hopefully another
Pokemon part two terrine I mean to be
fair that the director was like very bad
I mean wouldn't you agree attic that it
was kind of bare so I mean there's
before they dedicated a whole III - it's
all you scaring me don't say that like
so you saying because of how bear it was
there's a chance they could do another
in art without a doubt in death Pokemon
bundles dude bikes exclusive bundles
come in they got a detail those comin it
not being I think that they're a three
is gonna be dedicated to Animal Crossing
in public and that that's all you're
gonna see is those two I just don't want
it to 15 minute Pokemon great I think
he's gonna be dedicated to the game pass
no I think this is the year that you
gonna get that sideshow merger with the
xbox little show and the the the tree
house so his endo is is Phil Vaughn
Walker on these days okay so this is our
thing remember when they did that drink
will you be soft and my mother all that
was late yes it was it was awesome right
but it felt like wow that's kind of
different money when they did it and
that was like a prelude of what's coming
next a new direction of Nintendo because
we didn't think that they would do it in
that fashion with that game that game
was really good um so honestly if game
past is going to be on a switch and it's
going to be announced in a big way you
bring in top-tier graphics to the switch
okay so that's gonna be talked about and
it has to be talked about in a big
fashion of course you're gonna core
cross-promote
this is probably the year that Nintendo
shows up on an e3 stage number days they
stepped away from e3 they've been doing
directs so you might see my Yamato on
the stage just to confirm the
partnership if it's going forward I mean
there's a lot of TVs did they keep
leaving breadcrumbs and showing you
going forward they're gonna do this
thing it has to be announced in such a
big way that is a huge success and is
beneficial for Pope they'll shout the
meds in the chat he agrees King is right
he thinks gonna be game passed shot the
slow-mo my Astro chain-gang give it a
look lit back yeah well hopefully show
that you don't say it's in though you're
gonna give it all like he's out of
control you say they announced Metro for
like two years again advance its match
with you
we gonna see there and that he says I
need to see Doug Bowser's in a Bowser
costume walk up to Phil
while he's wearing Chiefs armor and them
shake hands on man some nose kind of
notices if it would have been something
else about Switch that this man would
have talked about the switch for the
next 30 minutes
I'm kind of oh you know you know that
you know what's really good it's
portable man you know the nd so so well
on this side we would've heard that for
another 20 minutes
we got a move on you got it boy you got
a lot of [ __ ] listen that's for you you
know I'm like fraud with that you know
he's so by the end of the day is just
too much the $60 it's not six delegate
for me but that's just my opinion I know
I'm in the minority many people are
going to buy this game outside of me
kiss moving to chat what y'all talk
about we talking about halo right now
right in time kid
so anyway oh yeah man we got some news
man so shout out to around McCafferty
and unfiltered series yet Barney Ross on
and a head of 343 and a little bit was
talked about this uh you know infinite
man and I want to bring this to the Lord
so it looks like brawny she was talking
about you know the 343 I guess their
trials or tribulations with each you
know iteration some things they do good
some things they did bad and then she
kind of dropped what I consider a
bombshell Inferno and she's talked about
they're looking at halo infinite as a
spiritual reboot to this series so I
wanted to all bring this to the Lord
obviously we know about the trailer hold
on shout out to kiss along with the file
I was super chat anything to these
Nintendo characters being on the Xbox
Dashboard I don't know brother you gotta
tell me I didn't even know about that
that is that is new um but yeah I want
to bring it to the laws as far as our
body rots and let's start with infernal
you know think of ping know if we all
saw the trailer you know what are you
about the potential of this to be a
spiritual reboot of the franchise well
what's interesting is that I think she
used her words very carefully if I say
it's spiritual reboot right everyone's
kind of questioning what that means
I've heard some theories you know I
don't think necessarily they're going to
you know go away from the Canon of Halo
and like reverse I think that they're I
think by saying spiritual reboot it's
just essentially saying okay we're gonna
go back to what worked you know I mean
we're gonna go back to what people
resonated with like halo 5 right like
obviously that didn't work for a lot of
people Prometheans and work for a lot of
people you
I'm hearing people what do you say sir
what file files like lock a word for a
lot of baby dobot I'll just of the shade
continue take a lock okay yeah so yeah
exactly like lock did people people want
to be go back to the glory days but not
you know obviously it didn't Master
Chief collection so we've already
revisited the glory days literally but
in terms of like the the atmosphere the
feel of halo they want everything to
return back to the glory days obviously
and they want to assure the hardcore
people that you know the direction that
halo 5 looked like it was going in that
it's not I think they're gonna just
regroup here go back to the drawing
board a little bit and maybe not take it
in that original direction like they
were considering so I think that's what
they mean by spiritual reboot not
necessarily you know like we're gonna go
back to halo 1 again you know Oh shadow
johannes on the chat and kids move they
just sent me a link so apparently
multiple Nintendo characters have
appeared in a mixer banner on the Xbox
one dashboard live.com yes splatoon
characters right yeah it looks like yeah
marina folks will tune to she here and
um Nintendo characters now show on the
Xbox one mixer banner includes Isabel
Princess Peach - speedy chair who seemed
that an inkling girl from Super Smash
Brothers ultimate and there's evidence
so maybe something big that out the
tender life back on taking your hands up
thank you kids smooth that's crazy but
he always get focused back away a little
bit so you're taking again just to recap
inferno
you're thinking is this what she's
saying specially boo just kind of going
back to the roots but not necessarily
rebooting the franchise where you're
going right right exactly I think you
know I think it would be foolish to go
back in time and go do this again you
know go do the halo thing again
obviously
halo Master Chief collection you know
wasn't too great out of the gate but
that's because of bugs and stuff the
idea was great a lot of people loved
playing those games again me included
a lot of people who ran through those
campaigns again loved the good old days
and I think they got positive
reinforcement of that by you know how
many people actually did play through
those campaigns they have those numbers
and I think that the numbers were
actually pretty high on that so that's
why I think they're kind of revisiting
the drawing board a little bit not
necessarily like progressing the
evolution of the gameplay maybe they're
going to go back to some of the old
mechanics or something like that
interest they progressed too much I
won't pick up infinite right right yeah
I'm tired of this this thing where
people act like you know putting
sprinting in a transitory game is a bad
thing don't you touch my mouth why and
what's funny is people want to say here
in Blaine thirty four three but failed
you know apparently they have been
playing this game long because the
people who introduced sprinting in Halo
was was Bungie on reading but people
want to act like 343 invented that like
no it was in reach everyone say we halo
reaching today to be people think
there's we we're looking into that whole
mixer thing it's just mixer that's a
stream you have people you know some
people although you want saw said now
when they smoke this fire this is no
longer fire is late so we gonna see but
uh get over to the clowns man clowns man
what do you think about Bonnie statement
in reference to you know halo being a
spiritual you know it's hard for me to
say because I've never been like a
hardcore Halo fan so I really don't
understand the universe as well as some
of the Xbox fans out there one thing I
will say though is that I hope they keep
Cortana like I'm kind of like that
mischievous evil god complex they're not
going to know if you been playing all
five and four years now but apparently
they're not going to stop that that
storyline they're they're gonna continue
where they left off of Halo 5
I think necess I think this is mainly
gonna be the for the most part we're
gonna see some gameplay changes like
like an inferno said Oh daddy nerd he
said bring on a tree ox uh
that's your man it's your man aatrox is
a beast that they would be done if they
didn't use his character mmm interesting
no doubt so uh so clown just to
reiterate you kind of you're not sure
and just wait you just we were yet yeah
I'm just at the point where I really
don't know what they can do with halo
because I'm not so involved into their
universe I don't understand it
completely I just know that you know the
UNSC are like humans and then there's
floods and they kill them and that you
know all that kind of stuff so what
could get through invested gloves if
Cortana stays on the path like addict
says she's gonna um and she has the
intent on destroying mankind and working
with me maybe the Prometheans or
something that'd be kind of cool though
the parenthese already joined forces
with her I love it even more right now
what I think's gonna happen a tree
aux-in kurta Cortana is gonna manipulate
a tree ox ouch I don't a chalk a lot of
people that didn't play a tree alex is a
banished brute that was before the human
war the they've the coven was actually
fighting him for longer than they fought
the huge so powerful he's killing
Spartans right he's dad dude right item
three Spartans at once and he's he's
mowing off
you Scully was ill at Hillel was to all
three of them I think what I think
they're gonna do cuz here's the thing
Anna wants to use the Rings but at the
same time she don't want to kill Master
Chief that's why she tried to capture
him at the end of five she was trying to
preserve him she didn't want him dying
but he never weigh it she's not gonna
shoot those rings until she has secured
him so perfect person to do that without
killing him a tree ox mm-hmm that's
what's uh best was gonna I think you're
gonna see a movement of arbiter because
I think he's gonna go in here so you
know what we'll have to see grabbed said
they should replace Cortana with Alexei
stop it yeah let's get all assassin and
King in here man what you think man
reboot spiritual reboot well yeah I
would like to see them do somewhat like
Sony Santa Monica
with a doddle warrior my man assess I
mean I have like hail will be more like
MetroAccess right they have its open
world but it has like sections you know
you can you know do side things but you
know like a normal open world but then
it's a little more linear like the Hey
look I'm so which you literally stop a
jump in bed cuz you think I literally
gonna say that what is going on oh you
last this alright alright so first of
all it says I catch three four three
Studios head Bonnie Ross tonight on 60
minutes to 7:00 p.m. Eastern Standard
Time Pacific time discussing the
importance of STEM education for girls
alright so be on tonight so you can
catch that if you're Bonnie Ross which
I'll be watching today
um I don't think that halo infinite is
what I think it is I don't think it has
anything to do with the lineage of
exactly a halo one through five I don't
think so I think it's gonna be a
open-world halo game we're probably you
raise up Spartans and you become a
Spartan and you can get to level up and
be like an RPG type of game where you
have an open world where it's it's halo
infinite the infinite possibilities of
you as your own Spartan taking on these
of RPG elements because I mean you have
big studios that they're purchasing and
they can work in collaboration and
actually give you something definitely
different from what you've been getting
before all right because there's the
shouts and the cries has been a halo is
the same old halo and is boring right
alright so we'll give you a halo
infinite where they wanted it to expand
they want to reach all those are worlds
that's out there that you can go to now
could you imagine you getting into a
ship and you're going over to another
world and there's other missions and the
stuff that you have to do as a Spartan
and you're figuring out stuff and you
can band up with your team um and it has
different well I mean if they do that
they would have to it have to be a pre
sequel
right yeah and I believe that they
they're gonna work spiritual successor
is not going to be as a successor to the
next one it's going to be in in the
spirit of halo this game will be there I
don't really think it's going to be
because you did you notice that Spartan
and if they show people thought it was
like Master Chief but his legs loose
skinny oh right yeah when you looked at
it it looked like this the armor was
really it was like a different kind of
armor so I really don't believe that
that's how the game is gonna be then you
saw some of the military dudes right and
now I really honestly believe that it's
none so you wouldn't have your choice of
characters that you want to be you can
enhance them different stuff like that I
think that is is incredibly a better
idea than just another sequel to Halo
now you can also have another sequel to
Halo coming out or for those people that
want that that shooter to get that fix
out but this is where we're taking it
because we want to reach our broadband
but you can just jump in and play it now
if you're playing could you imagine this
right is in-game pass you're playing it
on your switch you jump in play your
character go to a plan and do some RPG
stuff you log back off but you can log
back on on your PC or whatever and your
character is going with you
so I think it's going to be something
completely different from the regular
shooter that we get from Halo okay I get
that but I I don't know like pardon me
Barbie no you're going attics I want to
ask kinga's I don't want to let you get
killed but my thing is because of all
the flack that they got last year right
ass Halo in sense of you didn't play
Master Chief enough right that was in
the narrative aspect so my thing is do
you think with infinite they can get
away with you not playing as chief again
cuz I think that was what really upset
people right amy was like I don't want
to play Locke I don't want to play his
team maybe their own chief mmm
so put your own face scan your own face
do you make your locker okay so what
about so no you're accountable
know how Master Chief no I'm the one I'm
cool they don't do Master Chief I'm
saying it right now the game's gonna
flow okay right here here's where that
theory might work and this is the part
right you want them to do something to
elevate it so it can live on right this
can separate them exactly from mangi if
this will accept the right three four
three completely away from bungee if
they take it into a different area
could you imagine you launch it onto a
planet and you have your gun you walking
through and you don't know what's going
on but you radio into your guys in a
halo or destiny type of field but it's
actually a real open world whereas RPG
elements and you're leveling up your
what did you get we're gonna do you drop
me that gun and you know that stuff is
is destiny yes because remember they
wanted them to do destiny in their vein
and Bungie wanted to do destiny right
right you can actually get that game
that you originally planned with that
RPG elements with all that stuff to keep
the longevity going that they can
constantly reinvest in that this game is
always being played in game past see
because a halo is beginning to end done
right but halo infinite is infinitely
playing with new content being dropped
in weekly monthly or you know you hardly
chat because y'all we out they was like
yo David no don't fight it just accept
it because you didn't want CDs you
wanted your cartridges you got CDs you
wanted to hold onto your CDs and now you
got did you do download stop fighting it
and just just think it because nobody
don't pay you you want to play that
Oh halo go loading on the remaster you
want it's right there for you but you
don't play it that's where the fraud
comes in because they lost a rematch
you didn't buy it you didn't play it so
Larry said we listen we got to get this
market because you got to think about
what's going to keep generations going
in game pass that in work that is too
funny but listen it I don't know man
this is what and you're gonna look at me
you're gonna come back and see capture
him because he knows too much
he's from the future let me bring it
back before I would get answer I got
back to the to the laws of the quarters
here like do you think I'm a sass that's
not what assassin and for like do you
think they can get away with not being
chief in infinite absolutely I father
like they have a lot Lord yeah because
they work so well for five could let
assassin continue if the game features a
lot Lord that game's addictive and all
the other stuff like it's actually good
mmm
maybe some of the die-hard Halo fans
maybe will appreciate got you okay so
you think that you think they can't do
it is in fur no I need answers man you
know I gotta be honest the more here
King talk about this the more I think
yeah Norman Kings side on this and they
could bring I think they can bring chief
in is like a mentor to like you're
building up of your spine you know I
mean he could be like the mentor
character of your created character I
think you guys secretly want this
franchise to die hold on to the old
diatribes of what's going on in the old
dogma you are never going to evolve they
have to it has to change
do you understand the people that
probably winning it and a lot of you
guys love that God of War you'll love
the direction of the winning i'ma old
folk hated it but there's a whole ton of
people that said man that was genius hmm
when that happens you know it'll be a
lot of young people to didn't play that
halo so you're so upset that how God a
war when you want them to butcher halo
for me now
with me purchase halo 1 I don't believe
that you add a 1 and turn on your light
on your gun and sword on the wall to
understand what the halo is probably
asking you if you have more time I have
mad hours and all the hey that is what
the franchise needs more time and
multiplayer let me tell you know yo the
kiddok chat is very conflicted slo-moes
which you don't get he said they can
introduce a new generation spawn make
one of them you get to create your
character you know shits is know if
that's completely against the Lord like
some completely okay I'm just telling
what the chat is saying they want halo
to evolve your onl G stay he says no
King God of War still had Kratos oh yeah
the black Chris was white wow I'm gonna
get clown I see we got another Lord in
the building that's just joined so
clowns first um do you think they can
get away without Master Chief and
infinite yeah you know and a lot of
people are gonna hate you for this okay
and I'm gonna be completely 100% honest
I think it's time for Master Chief to
retire or die I spawned somebody new in
his place you know for this new
generation no Master Chief could always
come back in like different pieces
maybe he's brain in the computer or
something but I think it's time dude I
just think it's time let me ask with the
old in with the new
whoa name me a couple games were about
five six games in they just changed the
main antagonist and it went well this is
what you're confusing I want you I want
examples of where this works yeah what
you talking about okay this is where I'm
addressing that part because you are
addressing something that is holding
that you're holding on to what I'm
saying is I don't think this game is
what you perceive it to be I perceive
the game to be something completely you
have to look at the models that they're
going forward with proficiently playing
engagement level game
that aim that you talking has a
beginning and has an end
there's no persistence in playing that
doesn't with the motto of game paths
going forward to keep people engaging
logging in and playing if you're giving
them something that's that's why the
infinite is so important in the name
okay so you looking at that directly I
already I already got you there because
they say after Halo 5 that they're no
longer no they said before halo 5
dropped that they are good and are not
numbering any of their games anymore
it's always gonna be able to fire a halo
guardians halo infinite you guys kid
like a better king of the generation
speaking of which we got a Lord Smoove
in the building droplets some halo
knowledge on us man what do you think
yeah you guys I have the unpopular
opinion actually team lock so I feel a
halo can the way they can do it is just
that only way they can do it is if
Master Chief is not present at all yeah
God how they did would reach God so
reach was a successful Halo game that
didn't feature no parts of chief same
thing would be st feature no chief at
off-guard Nia's probably would have been
successful if it wasn't halo 5 guardians
they should have just been halo
guardians and kept chief out the hunt
could have been for chief but not had
you featured cheap at all the game would
have preferred much better if you never
liked pretty much found cheating right
oh you played the whole game through
lock in that whole team right and I feel
like I now it would be ok the problem is
halo Infinite can't be that because the
promises they made after halo 5
guardians they made to me say oh we're
gonna focus on chief
oh we're not gonna make that mistake
again so it's like the only way they can
really do it because they can put
infinite which could be an awesome game
and not few chief at all but think your
blood
well what happened to chief good I mean
like how long you're gonna lay that out
you right so you think they can all feel
bass would you say you think they can't
afford to go another Halo franchise
right I think I think hey let's go like
they don't got another one
like if 34 3 don't correct the boat
it's around this game it's rap because
it the fact that you know the
multiplayer is here's the thing like I
feel like if they've the multiplayer was
so good and I feel like if they divert
the ship to try to brain halo to a
completely different direction they're
gonna screw up the multiplayer in the in
the process what do you mean worried
about the multi people that is literally
the bulk of the game they can't they
can't pull a destiny right you know for
example right destiny is this shared
world experience right but they do have
this PvP mode where it's like completely
different from shared work experience
where is just PvP they can do that with
Halo easily if they want we keep that
same Slayer alright we're just gonna go
here to plan Slayer orange and yeah yeah
I want to get some comments in that was
lit alright slow most makeup if you had
it he said how is an infinite series
when you create your own character
against the law have you read the books
he said there's always generational
Spartans after the Master Chief
generation and then I want to shout out
drew he's saying that um you can't get
away with not having the main character
in look at what gears did as far as not
having Marcus Fenix so they they kind of
come a free attic yeah Argos was a
bystander in Gears for they could do it
what do you you you still feel it would
be a huge mistake from I think if if
they go that direction they don't focus
on you know the direction of the story
they have now I feel like you're gonna
have mixed emotions they're gonna have
people thinking that you know they're
pretty much declaring that the Halo
brand was was completely in the wrong
direction I think you're gonna have and
especially if you go that way you're
gonna completely completely isolate the
fans that made the franchise they're
going to because right load well halo 5
right now the bulk of the Halo community
or they like the way you know that the
general besides the campaign they like
the way halos going if you go away from
it again you're not getting them okay
I'll check this right check this imagine
they give you what I said and give you
all that pvp and PVE stuff that you like
right now imagine just like kids move
said you know how destiny has the two
separate
things you want to go play class you
want to go play trials you want to go
play this you want to go play this this
is a separate playlist for you if you
want to go do strikes there's a separate
playlist for you I just why we already
turn halo in a destiny because that's
what it was originally going to be I
mean he's gonna be that everything's
gonna be that show me when they said
that halo was going to be destined you'd
never gonna get those papers get those
papers but my thing is I don't
understand why you are so resistant if I
told you because right here everything
in or Luchino trying to make everything
into it I said open world RPG that you
can play with your friends so that's a
strike and as I said the strike you said
what are we supposed to do counter
strikes over for I said listen also you
have your M your PvP that did the only
thing that you played the only thing you
play I said okay I give that to you
never ever said that only played I
probably know more about the halo lore
than anyone I don't know you can bring a
point and say you ain't know more about
this and you can't see here and D value
my opinion because I don't play the
story when I know more about the Lord
that you do you know this is true you do
know more about the Lord you care about
it more than I do
I'm easily able to let it go but you're
holding on with both hands and feet
scream and keep me in the same failed
position so why the hell would you stay
in a situation that is failing wouldn't
you try to say you'll listen we got to
switch this around we must change let me
jump in real quick let me ask King this
in defense of attics point the consensus
with five was that the multiplayer was
amazing right but narrative in four was
a little shaky right they were all over
but and part of it people felt like yo
you didn't have enough chiefing so again
III do understand a little bit more
attic saying not that I don't thank you
at your point which is old we got to
evolve the series right
you took my let's take it to the next
level my castle on some service let's
kind of do infinite in that vein right
what to the crowd that was really upset
with fire they were like yo you better
have halo I'm a Master Chief in it or is
gonna be a problem when I think you
think they have to now at least satisfy
that base that felt so upset about
Guardians character it would be like
Craig now listen it didn't evolve it
didn't say they did evolve or GI okay
they people hated halo halo 4 I loved it
I loved the story I loved the fun of it
I loved playing it from beginning to end
and I never went back you know
everything has to be played for six
months at a time when you are looking
for engagement numbers
oh my they're trying to push right I'm
trying to explain to you what a company
is doing and they're showing you we are
doing this this is going to be the new
thing that engagement that's why apex
comes out people are playing it and
they're getting in there getting out but
they're back to engagement is this all
about how many times you're going to go
in and how many times you're going to
play said game in a date how many hours
you're gonna put in in their game it's a
game pass game I'll give you them what
about what about we meet in the middle
right what am i who what attic says with
the narrative campaign with whatever
whatever
didn't help me on this Inferno and in a
kiss more if you can didn't they
introduce war zones to beat it's like
kind of persistent thing or correct me
on am I wrong with it wait where does
war zones
they supported war zone about three
years after the game came out so it's
still it's one of their top modes or no
like what's the metrics look what they
don't support it anymore because it came
out in 2015 but they supported it for
about three years there was constant
updates coming to it they did drastic
you know they updated the cosmetic
system they gave them do new bosses in a
war zone they did plenty of stuff like
that mm-hmm
like no one had okay when it comes to
halo no one had to issue at the
multiplayer no one had to issue it
warzone people at issue with the story
and what's that is corrected people will
be completely on it but if you start
changing the foundation halos built on
you might as well just go ahead and
cancel the whole studio I hate but
here's the thing so you know it can't
afford in no capacity to say that this
is a spiritual reboot that you create
your own Spartan and that let's say I'm
doing the automatically is like 10% okay
all right let me jump in this I think
this is gonna go left like this is good
oh yeah this is a hot way this is
intriguing this is a cheating um
I agree with Japan we I mean the multi
play at three foot three nailed it right
they don't need to touch that at all um
I got a green King a little bit I think
if a reboot is done right and again it's
very touchy when you reboot you know
these iconic franchises right but you
know it could be the boost that they
need to kind of get that redundant story
loop and make up for a let's be honest
hey let's say right now if they mess up
a well I would sell my xbox and I'll
never touch a Microsoft problem will it
come no when it comes to Microsoft
I value halo and I value fable for
everything else if they mess up halo I'm
done well I'm not even joking I have you
done I feel you all I'm gonna say is
this let's let's put ourselves in a time
capsule all the lords here was put I put
up any target now let's remember again
God of War remember the initial
reactions oh my god he can't jump
you know I'm saying what is called what
is this over-the-shoulder crap where is
that like it was a complete change right
like they literally reinvented it to
something now and we do know what
infinite there's a new graphics engine
now we are hearing rumors like kiss Musa
as well as a subspace engine FRA rumors
of um RPG mechanics they're talking
about storing choices you look excited
you know me so I mean this is definitely
a chance for three for three
to kind
make halo their own because let's be
honest they've been really refining the
Bungie thing you know I'm saying it say
it again I'm not saying cuz what's our
did they resume right now quebra help me
out with three foot through all the
halos it's been halo 4 halo 5 Monica how
come combat Evolved the original warrior
halo 2 remake right they coat they co
hooked on Master Chief collection they
may form five okay but do you really
want to count like though remix you
gotta count their whole resume you just
look look they're looking at the same
thing but it looks better I mean 343 has
made the better the best performing
halos ever under 343 halo has run at 60
frames per second what performance and
multiply would oh yes Bungie still kind
of got them if you compare narrative Lee
you look better right graphically but
he's like okay he's a good kid I get I
want to bring it back as I know attic is
very passionate about it yeah and King
this is a you know to the point you guys
are bringing up like about this whole
like sometimes gamers do you think maybe
we hold on too much and it's like maybe
a situation where you know I King is
saying like he's making a valid point
and since that may be needing something
fresh maybe they need something new I've
seen too many of my beloved franchise
because people because people want to
refresh again and they completely go
away from what why did it 343 give up on
a Master Chief collection
hmm think about it they know halo
Infinite is gonna be so different from
the original Halo series that day maybe
they put in extra hours to fix
Master Chief collection so that people
who want the original Halo experiences
they got this whole collection that will
that will that will live for years and
years to come
those servers would never shut down so
joy boy hold on so I got about my
telephone all right quick
so you're thinking their dedication to
keeping Master Chief collection of love
if the base that once at hardcore a
thing to get over there because
otherwise they go their new direction
with infinite is that the possibilities
you're kidding yes
this halo I'm not gonna be happy right
now it's it's just a fun Bethany no no
just a fun one it is says a fable a hill
your tuba love franchise right so let's
just say it's what king says hey halo
and kiss would halo if it is some
completely different no mass achieved
create your Spartan complete different
thing from the timeline yada yada yada
what fable is the truth and they take it
back to the essence it is the fable you
love they take it back to the essence
it's gonna be trash I don't want it I
don't want that British humor stuff
let's just say if the fable you want in
every way you want clearly I'll play
fable I'm not joking you guys like if
they mess up halo like it's not gonna be
good at like I I don't think that they
can handle here's the thing
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
hopefully we gotta move Lord King you
are upsetting the panel I don't know
what happened it was like rage